in triangle and I said this to a few of
you but not to everyone please name your
triangles when you're talking about
things because this so many triangles
flying around can quite confusing this
is the triangle i'm looking at right now
this is the triangle on the ground
a CT raster suggested i used 10 turn of
that angle up there the orange one
what's it called what's its name T a B
or C 80 or be 80 I'm gonna call it B 80
that's the that's the triangle and after
in the end right it's gonna be yeah
batten captain acting all that it's
gonna be opposite on adjacent UK with
that opposite on adjacent in this big
triangle right so opposite will be H cot
look carefully
we tracked which which side am I looking
at H cut this is this is opposite right
here's my orange egg that's H cot 30
right there's the opposite what's the
adjacent side look carefully this is the
orange angle what's next to this orange
angle in this big right angle triangle
this guy right H client 26 degrees right
opposite on adjacent what happens
there's HS they can cancel out boom BAM
I should point out cot is just 1 over 10
right and I've got 1 over 10 this over 1
over 10 that so I can actually put
things put things back into tans right
that's gonna be a little bit simple for
me because you're gonna need to get your
calculator out right now yeah do you
want to ask me how I went from there to
there it's not the question if I had a
5th over a half a 5th over a half that's
put some brackets in there right what
does it mean to divide by a fraction
what do you usually do if you're just a
moment you would multiply by the
reciprocal right you'd multiply by the
reciprocal of this which is which is 2
right and then this guy here is going to
go down the bottom it's just divided by
5 right so that's what I've done here
it's just the tan in color they're
reciprocals so I've got this so far now
I'm gonna need your help with your
calculator I have no idea what 1026
degrees on 10 30 degrees is can you work
out for me please
yeah that's okay
Oh hold on a second 1026 degrees 10 30
degrees that's not an angle it's a ratio
right so you're gonna get zero point
something or other what do you get
really okay I just didn't write it down
there we go
do you have a question do you ever think
it's like this is - this is that your
question yeah okay so let's think about
what is what does cut mean what our
definition for khat like COD cut 30 is
one over ten thirty degrees that's
that's just what we define it to be okay
so if I've got caught ferry on caught 26
I have this over this do you agree is
that okay I'll do it really nice and
slow for you when you deal with the
equivalent fractions right for example 6
over 8 we would say that's equal to
please tell me no the accruing fraction
for 6 over 8 this is 3 over 4 and what
you've done is you've divided by 2 and
then you divided by 2 again right so
here's what I'm going to do here I'm
going to multiply this by 10 26 and I'm
gonna multiply this by 10 26 are you ok
with that still an equivalent fraction
right what happens on the denominator
what happens to them they they cancel
right is that okay you just get the 1 is
that all right
so now what I've got is 10 26 on 1030 on
the top that's the numerator all divided
by what which last I checked is 10 20
series on 10 30 degrees does that make
sense so sorry I had to break that apart
okay are we okay now that's all right
you've pressed 10 26 degrees on 1030
reason you calculate you've got this but
I'd actually want that I just want the
angle itself can someone tell me what
the actual angle is you're gonna have to
do shift 10 who's got it
40 can I get some decimal places on that
maybe maybe one decimal place will do
two things like one nine something or
other right let's just call it that okay
so what do I got here this is the orange
angle in here
this guy forty point two degrees now
we're still not there yet the blue angle
is the actual one we're interested in
but as John pointed out in this triangle
up here abt right you see this you've
got forty point two degrees it's
opposite this side and if we wanted this
angle here we've got our side opposite
that right this is which rule this is
the sine rule right let's write it out
in why am I using that color in triangle
a B T right my destination is going to
be this this unmarked angle here I
should give it up give it a color all
the rest of them have a color let's call
this one the green one right there's the
green angle in there it's a sign of what
is the name of the screen angle a abt
thank you very much and in the sign rule
we pair each angle with the opposite
sign what is the opposite side edge cot
26 thank you and then we've got sign on
top of the side so I've got do sign
what's my other angle the one I just
worked out yeah and the opposite side is
a all careful we're in this little
triangle it's why I even named it it's H
cot 28 right now I know this looks like
a garbled mess that's part of what makes
this problem challenging however I
should point out that and that and that
that's just mins before your calculator
and it looks awkward to write but your
calculator will take care of all of that
right I want a BT what happens when I
multiply this edge cot 26 to both sides
it's gonna end up on this side right and
you're gonna get an H on the top and an
H on the bottom that's
they'll cancel just like they did before
right so I'm gonna get this sign 40.2
sometimes have you guys ever tried to
clean up your desk before right and when
you clean up your desk halfway between
you know desk messy and desk clean
there's like room messy because you're
like oh where does all of this go things
have to get worse before they get better
that's kind of where we are here okay
now can you please do me a favor you can
pop this into a calculator again I'll do
one more line for you that might make it
a little bit easier for you I'm going to
write this is 10 and this is 10 just be
careful you don't mix up your angles
because you'll get a completely
different result and then we're gonna do
shifts time to get that angle out now I
have a number but I'm waiting for you
guys to confirm for me what you think it
is where am I gonna go
let's see if I can squeeze my working in
here that's gonna be really brave what
do you want your answer I had different
verses that's again that's okay
which angle is that can you show me
around this without that this bad boy
right here
so what you've done is yeah okay I'm
gonna tell you it's not but it's
actually close you hadn't there was a an
issue that you had earlier on where
there was a different there was an angle
that could be something other than what
you've worked out which is why that
earlier error leads you to this one okay
so keeping you know you know you're not
quite there but you're on the right
track
28 degrees 11 minutes really I got
something else three I have 44.7 yeah
44.7 there might be some decimal places
in there yeah make sure you're in
degrees that's gonna be at the start
that was just to have a look at it that
was just to get started I just said a
head start I didn't tell you to do the
whole thing all right here's what I've
got my calculator tells me about forty
four point seven degrees okay roughly
now you have to be super cautious
remember in the past we've talked about
the fact that you've got the sine rule
you've got the cosine rule when we can
we prefer the cosine rule because it has
well you never have a problem with
ambiguity right remember that so this is
one of the angles but there's another
option right what's the other option
180 degrees minus that oh wow that will
happen fast I think I'm getting this as
the other option okay now here's on then
do we have zero tomorrow don't we yeah
we do okay
he's not gonna do I'm gonna leave that
there if you didn't keep up writing
maybe go ahead and take a picture but
we're not out of the woods yet we're not
out of the woods so we're gonna continue
this in zero you are welcome to see if
you can get from here to the end but
then we're going to continue the
discussion because there's still a
couple of curveballs left okay